es sind bilder wie aus einem
katastrophenfilm als hätten es die
regisseure hollywoods selbst inszeniert
kalifornien golden state jetzt ein
abgebranntes paradies wir sind unterwegs
nördlich von los angeles waren
kilometerweit durch trostloses land
juniper hills eine gemeinde in den san
gabriel bergen nur eineinhalb
autostunden von seoul entfernt
das ist alles was von meinem haus übrig
geblieben ist cherilyn dexter künstlerin
designerin die retterin schauen sie sich
diesen blick an
das war mein tor und jetzt feuer opfer
die flammen haben ihre point dexter rose
ranch bis auf die grundmauern
niedergebrannt
das ist mein wohnzimmer und meine vogel
da waren meine papageien drin
ein schöner kamin ist das wunderbare
kunst sammlerstücke designer stünde der
kronleuchter meiner mutter cheryl hatte
keine zeit ihr hab und gut zu retten
alles was sie mitnehmen konnte waren die
tiere und das auch nur weil die nachbarn
halfen
ich hatte hier pferde
ich hätte pferde vor dem abgang
papageien schweine hühner enten ich
hatte einen großen ententeich hier und
einen hühnerstall
das ist alles weg alles ist weg
alles steht in flammen mehr als 20
brände toben in amerikas westen
in der korona krise kurz vor der
präsidentschaftswahl
es brennt fast überall an der westküste
die san francisco bay bridge genauso wie
die skyline der stadt der engel kaum zu
sehen
aber es brennt auch in oregon und
washington state fast 20.000
feuerwehrleute sind im einsatz gegen die
flammen
die waldbrände in diesem jahr so schlimm
wie nie zuvor
vergangene woche treffen wir jeff und
seine familie in jennifer hills
da stehen die flammen noch kurz vor
seinem grundstück der stellvertretende
sheriff kann hier hoch und sagte hey ist
weg das ist eine anordnung
ich habe gesagt klar ich weiß dass ich
habe schon auf euch gewartet und nein
ich gehe nicht bis das feuer das haus
von dalian und lyonel niederbrennt
während jeff ausharren will ist seine
frau mit packen beschäftigt leichte
meinungsverschiedenheiten deshalb sind
sie sauer auf ihn ja ich bin stinksauer
weil der nicht hilft und lieber mit euch
quatscht sharepoint exter hatte keine
zeit zum nachdenken ob sie geht oder
lieber bleibt der evakuierungsbefehl kam
ende der woche kurz bevor die flammen
ihr haus auf rasen
jetzt macht sie sich gedanken darüber
wer eigentlich schuld hat an der
schlimmsten brandkatastrophe der
kalifornischen geschichte wir haben den
planeten zerstört ich meine wir haben
sehr wenig respekt und so sehr ich trump
auch mark für die umwelt tut er gar
nicht dass cheryl und ihre freunde nicht
davon abhält am präsidenten festzuhalten
die demokraten schließlich hätten auch
ihr kalifornien zu grunde gerichtet
kalifornien wird schlecht regiert
wirklich schlecht ich meine man kann es
sich kaum leisten hier zu leben und dann
geben sie das ganze geld in obdachlos
und dann machen sie uns alle obdach
juniper holzes trump land mitten im
liberalen kalifornien der us präsident
nutzte die katastrophe für den wahlkampf
und einen inzwischen legendären auftritt
allein die schlechte forstwirtschaft der
demokraten sei der grund für die brände
nicht der klimawandel
wir möchten mit ihnen daran arbeiten im
klimawandel anzuerkennen was er für
unsere wälder bedeutet wir möchten mit
wissenschaftlichen daten ab diese
wissenschaft ist entscheidend wenn wir
sie ignorieren und unserem kopf in den
sand stecken und glauben es liegt nur an
der forstwirtschaft werden wir die
california nicht schützen kann
es wird kühler werden ich wünschte die
wissenschaft sehe das genauso
ich glaube nicht dass die wissenschaft
das beurteilen kann
die replik vom herausforderer joe biden
kommt noch am selben tag
donald trump ist ein klima brandstifter
wenn er noch mal vier jahre im weißen
haus sitzt wer wäre überrascht dass noch
mehr teile amerikas in flammen aufgehen
und weil die katastrophe mitten in den
wahlkampf feld hat sie all das
politische potenzial für noch mehr
spaltung für noch mehr konflikt diese
gereizte stimmung spürt sharepoint exter
auch aber jetzt gerade hat sie andere
sorgen
[Applaus]
ich hatte diese fische 13 jahre lang die
waren wunderschön
eigentlich erzählt und sheryl stamme sie
aus texas kalifornien aber seit 60
jahren ihre heimat den lone star state
habe sie damals gerne eingetauscht gegen
den golden state nicht zuletzt wegen der
menschen hier die auch jetzt zu erhalten
in der stunde der not die ganze
nachbarschaft ist vorbeigekommen und sie
haben mir sachen gebracht bier und
geschirr und handtücher die ganze
nachbarschaft
das war einfach so schön die feuer im
westen der usa für die menschen in
jennifer hills geht es vor allem um
zusammenhalt im entfernung um ihre
existenz wahlkampf hin oder her
[Musik]